this is the saddest story in our
politics right now forget about Biden
forget about Trump forget about war
forget about disease forget about
did you know that the late night TV
hosts have been out of work for well
over three months now probably you
didn't if you did it's because I
mentioned it once a couple of weeks ago
which was the first time that I realized
it because there's a writer's strike in
Hollywood so the wgas on strike which
means the writers for the late night
shows are on strike which means the
shows are in reruns and nobody noticed
it because very very few people watch
these shows anymore so in order to fight
back against this and try to make some
money for the staff of these shows
all of the big late night hosts Stephen
Colbert Jimmy Kimmel Jimmy Fallon Seth
Meyers all of these guys
are doing what what all white men in
America
or obliged to do
which is start a podcast here's their
podcast
one more time Jimmy
hi I'm Jimmy Fallon I'm Stephen Colbert
I'm Jimmy Kimmel I thought when you said
Jimmy you meant me Jimmy but you meant
Jimmy Jimmy I always mean you but when
you always be at Myers who do you mean I
mean John Oliver makes the five of us
together for uh maybe an hour a day
Strike Force Five is the name of our
podcast subscribe to it now
Spotify or wherever else you get your
podcasts
but Spotify you
oh my fight my face is never going to
lose this permanent state of cringe
do you get it I was talking to the one
Jimmy not the other Jimmy and then and
then they all try to get their little
line in there and then John Oliver who I
forgot was even in the podcast he just
does the John Oliver routine which is he
says something not funny but then he
says the f word afterward so that's
supposed to pass for comedy and
this was a revelation to me
and it's a revelation because when I was
a kid
Johnny Carson Jay Leno David Letterman
these were huge Stars these guys hosted
the the initially it was just one late
night show then it was you know two then
three then four late night shows but
still these were huge huge shows they
commanded a huge audience and now all of
these guys the hosts of the supposed big
late night shows these are franchises
that go back decades in network
television they have the same job that I
do we have the exact same job now
we just have podcasts
and this isn't merely a way to get
around the writer's strike and remain
relevant and stay in the news and maybe
make some money for the staff
this is true even when they're on TV
this is why no one noticed that they
were off air
because they're audiences which used to
be gigantic have dwindled down to very
very little Johnny Carson on his last
week on air
averaged 19 million viewers per show
his final show Johnny Carson's final
show
had 50 million viewers
and by the way this was in 1992 the U.S
population in 1992 was just north of 250
million people today it's something like
330 million people so the equivalent
today to 50 million viewers the last the
last night of the Johnny Carson show
would be equivalent to
65-ish million viewers today
what are these guys getting these guys
are pulling in
a million people a night
maybe maybe a little more sometimes
significantly less than that half a
million people a night for Seth Meyers I
think
that's a podcast
the major Network late night shows have
become
a podcast and so
any continued Allure of the
establishment media is a virtual
potemkin Village the culture has just
divided up there's no there's no one
thing that commands all of the eyeballs
probably until the Trump show trial that
will probably be the highest ratings of
any television program in decades but
that's all divided up and and this is
important for a political order because
the ruling class was able to exert a lot
of soft power when everyone was tuned in
certainly to the three network
television stations and then even with
cable people were still watching a lot
of the same kind of stuff so you can
exert a lot of soft power through
propaganda and conditioning but when
that totally breaks up and everyone's
just listening to their own podcasts
which get what a million views or even
half a million views some podcasts get
very fewer and still have a devoted
following well then the political orders
got to get a little tougher if they
can't exert that soft power and people
are starting to ask questions and people
are starting to question things and
people are starting to think for
themselves then the enforcement
mechanism of the state is going to get a
lot tougher and it's going to start
cracking down on dissidents it's going
to start arresting people who question
the ruling class as we are seeing every
single single day that is the
consequence of a breakdown of the common
culture maybe it's a good thing because
we're not all as hypnotized as we used
to be but now the the bare reality of
our political order and the coercion
that it entails is is becoming much
clearer and we've got to talk about that
when you want to talk to your friends
you got to check out pure talk right now
go to puretalk.com Knowles is your cell
phone in desperate need of a replacement
you know the signs your battery life is
so short that you gotta have a charger
on hand all the time cracked screen that
gives you glass splinters it's time to
put that old phone to rest and upgrade
to a new 5G Samsung Galaxy from Pure
Talk for free get a free 5G Samsung
Galaxy with two day battery life edge to
edge display and Ultra strong Gorilla
Glass when you sign up for Pure talks
unlimited talk text and 15 gig data plan
for just 35 bucks a month plus it comes
with a mobile hotspot you're not using
pure talk you are simply paying too much
that's the rule okay get all the data
that you could ever need for half the
price of the big carriers on America's
Most Dependable 5G network not a
similarly Dependable Network the most
Dependable 5G Network go to
puretalk.comwles for your free super
durable 5G Samsung Galaxy when you
switch to Pure Talk
puretalk.com Knowles make the switch to
my cell phone company that I use
puretalk the official Wireless partner
of the daily wire hi Michael it's Kyle C
here first I wanted to say that I really
appreciate your straightforward and
honest assessment of the state of the
GOP Ray so far I personally think you do
the best out of any commentators in
giving analysis of the race
so my question is related to it and
specifically about how the Democrats are
clearly interested in bringing back
covert lockdowns and rules back into
society in my opinion one of the biggest
problems for Rhonda Sanders's campaign
is that arguably his biggest strength
and comparison to Trump is the handling
of kovid but people have basically
forgotten about it or don't really care
to talk about covid anymore so with this
renewed interest from Democrats bringing
back the covet craziness do you think
the spotlight on this will help the
DeSantis campaign at all enough to
bridge the massive lead that Trump holds
right now or do you think it will have
little to no boost for him I'd really
appreciate your thoughts thank you very
much yes I think this is desantis's best
shot right now the Democrats are testing
out whether or not we have the stomach
for covid Insanity again so they're
doing it one school one company in one
industry okay now maybe it's two schools
and they're they're just testing it to
see if we'll we'll will go along with it
and people probably will because it was
politically very effective for the
Democrats so desantis's Best Shot
certainly is to remind people that he
was very strong during covid I'm not
convinced this whole even that would
bring him across the Finish Line because
DeSantis will continue to govern well on
kovid and Trump will not have any
responsibility he'll just be on the
campaign Trail and he can say whatever
he wants and come out strongly against
the covid lockdowns and it'll sound just
as good you know in the same way that
Vivek ramaswamy has has never held
public office but he says things that
are very appealing and he's and he's had
a successful career in private
Enterprise so when he says things he
gets just as much credit if not more
credit than Governors or Senators who
have who have been in the government
Arena on those issues that would be my
guess
if
DeSantis can really tie fauci around
Trump's neck it might help pull him down
I do agree it's his best shot I'm not
sure it's enough but it but it's his
best shot boy what a great clip that was
now
make sure that you ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel see you next time